happy holidays everyone this time of
celebration comes once a year
so do our awesome new holiday items of
course
you made sure to be good all year round
make sure you save some bucks to get
yourself the gift
that you most surely deserve make it to
the top of the leaderboards and you'll
get some gold
frankincense and mirror or their in-game
equivalent
and may your winter be as fun as winter
can be
[Music]
good morning gamers it's a beautiful day
yeah look at you okay guys very
important thing
if you look at his ass you can see
there's a bunch of stuff in there
that's because he doesn't have a beehive
and i can relate to that having a bunch
of stuff in my ass that is
so anyway we need to get a beehive and
to do so
i have something special in mind yes
stop stop i know i'm not i'm not go no
not go near your butt okay first of all
i want to go as far as i can into the
nether because i
try to explore my area and i find
nothing
nothing so we're going to use a portal
in the
you guys probably don't know this
you travel longer in the nether yeah all
right i need some uh
obsidian yeah hope i don't die
thank you we're playing a hardcore which
means of course i die i die
here we go jesus christ
we're fine okay we got ten nice adios
i ain't scared of nothing i can't die
i haven't died my entire life i'm not
diet dating you know i realize minecraft
is a little bit like uh
gambling because here i am on the floor
where the
diamonds are and i'm kind of like yeah
maybe i'll maybe i'll find some diamonds
i'll just take a little bit just a light
a little bit
i need silk touch for my axe because
then um
god oh that's how i get the beehive i
know minecraft i'm a veteran pay respect
smash like subscribe on this video now
smash that like and
hey red diamond we found it
is this what is this
it's nothing it's garbage it's mean
nothing to me bro i need coal
should i be scared there's like no
enemies in this
oh jeff ball every
ah no no like this
[Music]
stick me back take me back get me out of
here
come at me come at me i smite thee
you couldn't hit a child like point
blank range
i can hit them easy this is nothing
oh that's a lot of them
[Applause]
oh my god is there a spawner or
something what's happening chief aliba
i got a trick
i gotta start up set up a perimeter
yeah oh i didn't think this through
i didn't think this through back off
why there's got to be a spawner here
i could be rich see i told you minecraft
is like gambling oh god
i'm so slow at killing them oh don't i
don't i'm looking
i'm not looking i'm not looking i'm not
looking bro
oh god oh no this is it thanks for
sticking with my dinner
this sucks this absolutely sucks i'm not
looking bro
jesus christ this sucks i need to get
out of here
asap
okay i'm not idiot
he's on fire dumb man
oh my god oh god oh god
cole why was i here again i forgot how
did i end up on this
you made me you may want to ever get in
me can i kill him
i mean it is tempting i do need ender
pearls
no
creepers suck so hard dude all right
he's really following me
what if i place like fire all around him
he's so dumb he does an aggro i'm a
genius
i came for diamonds and i left with
tears
what is this i thought there was a
spawner here gold
oh this is perfect i need this for the
nether i was actually just testing you
guys last episode
when i didn't wear gold in the nether
that's a test then
you all failed what was that
no diamonds all right fine we're going
we're going to the nether
this is too dangerous even for a
minecraft veteran like myself
nope i saw you
oh i saw you cousin too
[Music]
sorry he had to die i know you can save
them but i yeah
die okay this is too much where are my
torches
i ain't afraid of nothing because i'm
not a coward oh god
this is a bad idea i should leave oh my
god
damn son so where are they all coming
from
oh my god you scared me dude i don't
like you
sorry spider no
oh my god
it's worth it i'm out of wood maybe i
should leave
that's what a coward would say that's
when you keep going
oh that's a spawner that's spawner i
found a spawner
oh god
okay cool that was worth it that was
actually worth it
holy cow so since i i play on hardcore
i think it's fair to i think it's fair
to use the debug menu and check the
check coordinates and stuff like that
that's what the word would say i ain't
checking coordinates for sh
i don't need it i got coordinates in my
brain numbers
bing bong swing smong you know what i
mean all right let's get out of here
[Music]
oh my gosh that's what
i am a dwarf and i'm digging a hole
and digging a hole how
deep was i jesus
oh no it's no one invited you this is my
hole
idiot is that my house over there yeah
oh god oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no we don't do that
here
we don't do that here i need you
yes home sweet alabama
fine this is all your this i'm gonna
kill you as soon as i wake up
hey that was the worst
my gosh i didn't get anything i'm poor
well we got a lot of gold actually guys
a lot of people don't know this
you can actually have seven furnaces
yeah but you didn't know that
dummy okay so i'm going in the nether
i need that gold and i need it flipping
fast i know you have to go
i'm trying here all right so what should
i make gold boots
why oh feather falling
whoa that's actually really good sorry
diamond
boots do you get the rest okay
be right back i love you time to frick
the cows
i mean feed the cow sorry now freak
free i don't care if it's your brother
or sister just
please i need more meat please
hey you at the back don't try to hide
okay i gotta kill some of them
i need like an observation area i need
to grab your me
sorry children try not to be as useless
as your parents
don't follow me don't follow me
[Music]
okay so we're gonna go far
far as hell
just gotta make it safe right yeah
that's safe
someone's shooting me from the trees
that's impossible
oh he's riding it oh the babies are back
oh my god they're teaming up
oh it's time
you must do the wrong wrong one i come
from the dream
i'm friends with them oh god i will
yeah i will kill your child so hard dude
stop stop doing that oh you're too fat
oh your baby's too
useless how did that feel how does dead
feel
oh was there a little in here
stop that i could actually die this is
not funny all right
oh god a lot of people don't know this
but you can actually make
a lot of
[Laughter]
you can make furnace that's what i was
saying in nether
all right well that cooks i'll kill the
child
jesus they're so annoying
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm alive
uh a child is not gonna kill me yeah
run idiot i see you
damn they do a lot of damage how does
dead feel
dumbass all right i actually want to
trade with the
because i have a ton of gold there
you are how you doing
fellow poor person oh sorry
okay listen i'm going to give you stuff
and you give me stuff
bro stop giving me garbage you know what
i want
are you serious okay there's more of
them over here
but i think i just pissed someone off oh
they killed him well done sir we share a
common goal of hating pigs
bro minecraft is gambling i i understand
that
see maybe uh i like you guys
see they attack me if i don't have gold
on me we hate poor people
equally i like that i like that okay on
with the tunnel
i got a bunch of arrows and tears it's
like christmas as a child again
nope nope we don't do that here
yes oh no no no no no no i don't think
so lava
i don't think so
[Applause]
what did i do what did i do what did i
do what did i do what did i do
oh my god what did i do i didn't do
nothing i'm wearing with the boots oh
god i'm gonna die
no hole in the wall where did it even
come from
i need a new shield now can i make a
shield oh thank god
okay let's continue i wasn't even scared
oh we made it to the other side
all right so here's pretty safe is a
good place to probably build a portal
that's what the cow would say we keep
going baby
i'm afraid of nothing nothing you don't
shoot me right
we cool a child can never kill me
they're weak small and ugly what's the
worst thing that can happen
the minecraft series is over don't worry
i can't die
don't worry don't worry i can't die i
can't die too strong too strong
should probably look where i'm going
right oh god
oh god it's i got one of those moments
where you look down i'm not doing this
hell no oh why'd i do this oh no
i'm actually sweating hey guys just a
swedish man passing through
nothing didn't see i hate bridges
always has been oh my god
should we just do one i'll just guys i'm
building here
away all right there better be something
good in here
after all the trouble i went through all
right
what are we gonna find whatever it is
i'm ready for it
let's go
sand sand dude
what is this that looks identical to
ah cool we found the sand island guys we
did it
i'm gonna keep going no fear
no fear this is a no coward play through
anyone can be minecraft hardcore playing
like a wheelbarrow
hey me amy hey
we must go deeper oh
another biome kind of want to check it
out
in case we need to bail we do it fast
sheesh luishon my speech speeches
all right we can do this just don't die
how hard is it
not hard
oh my god stop
stop i said stop not one second more
one more inch and yeah yeah
do i neither magma magma
this up this is my bridge
off
come on come on
owl come on come on
come on come on yeah
epic i'm the best goddamn gamer on the
planet
i'm friends with the bees that's right
from the trees
that drag on the day oh i ain't scared
we're going really far
i ain't scared of nothing nothing trust
me it would be worth it trust me
all right it's not worth it it's not
worth it why
has to be lava everywhere dude if you're
feeling scared right now
just know you're the only one coward
i feel nothing oh dude my my diamond
pickaxe is gonna go bye-bye very soon
okay fine fine i'll build one here
crying obsidian
why are you crying obsidian can you mix
them that's the real question isn't it
all right hopefully this works i don't
see why not
q-mojang mojang oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god
not like this
i got it
come on
almost had it all right all right i out
of sight out of mine out of sight out of
my
we're fine this is the safest bridge in
the world trust me
swedish engineers made it literally
all right let's try that again shall we
give me something good give me something
good
come on
bro that looks like my house that looks
like my backyard
okay i guess snow is cool oh they got
chicken here that's amazing
chickens are super rare oh my god sheep
yes i need a bed so bad dude
here little chickpea hey hey
i need a bed i need a bed
oh i can finally sleep let's go in the
snowy mountains maybe we can find bruno
mars
oh dude all right this is absolute
bull crap
oh my god
don't do it this is my home oh god he
does a lot of damage
i need trees please just one tree
they can't attack in the trees where's
my hole
where's my hole where's my
hole
there we go
no nightmare so loud thank you what i
killed the sheep
are you serious this is a joke am i
getting jokesters
i'm being tested right now did i throw
it away or something
all right there's got to be more sheeps
is that a horse
it's a horse oh my god just
jurgen jurgen smergen
i don't have time for you i'm gonna die
oh it's kidding it's getting bright it's
getting bright i just have to live a
little longer i just have to live a
little longer
no i'm eating a raw potato
why don't i have a bed yet
stop
i'm actually gonna die
[Music]
god
that's what a coward would say oh
boo i almost died didn't affect me
one bit if i don't get a bed soon i am
100 dying
oh target locked in sight dude
my god it's motherflipping snip snip
time
you're naked you're naked
you're dead arrogance
so beautiful i don't i didn't bring any
wheat
i can't interact with them i can just
say hello for now
oh they are so majestics oh
white rare jurgen rare right jurgen
hey hey hey
hey hey one day you will be mine
all right i'm infiltrating the fortress
i've officially
become afraid of nothing this is the
goal of this video now i'm infiltrating
that fortress
and then i'm leaving if i die so maybe
it here we go scythe you're the most
epic goddamn
sick you can find
oh it begins
they got a little shadow i mean i'm
infiltrating
i'm in well that
i could train smerg and perrigan
hey we should leave them something an
egg
oh there's a village there i got what i
came for
no reason to stay stick around you're
again
yeah again white jargon
white jargon
i just realized i need a saddle this is
completely pointless never mind
i was so ready for that well we can
check out the village
oh you're teasing me with your beauty
white jargon
tapa this morning i swear i saw a
village am i blind
did i think these are villages yeah i
thought that was a village it kind of
looked oh my god
okay well we've located the year again
now we know we just need to come back
i'm going back to
no i'm alive i'm alive i'm fine
didn't even flinch didn't even clinch
what are you
back to bet you thought i would say back
to base but that makes no sense
base isn't even a word
we made it back safe and sound god damn
miracle
you suck sorry
hey i'm sorry
i didn't really go as planned you know i
know you're happy to see me
but boy am i happier to see you one bed
for me
and one bed for bro let's sleep bro
oh okay we need a sado
the best way is the desert right because
we we can find a
samika badiko you know what i'm talking
about and they're usually
in those i can't stop playing this game
is too good got too much important stuff
to do we got to get a saddle
and ass is about to explode dude
is that one i think that that that's
that's one
that's one right there my eagle eyes my
swedish eagle eyes
so i found my way back my minecraft is
running at cyberpunk quality right now
what is happening
it's very important that we don't step
on the trap if we step on the trap we go
bye-bye
no year again nope i cannot live with
the fact
that would be alone so let's do this and
let's do it clean
side cue epic music
[Music]
oh geez
there she blows i'm infiltrated i mean
for jurgen yes
no no head come on
mending holy no say it said that
gasps yes
yes
i'm playing the tambourine i mean the
flute whatever it's called we're going
home we're going home to your
purple blog
okay never mind there's my checkpoint no
oh hey little
oh it's a baby bunny it's so baby and
cute
i've been playing for way too long
there's my beautiful house
my god it's gorgeous hey guys i got
great news
i got so much wheat that is all going to
jurgen and nothing to you
oh
hey you won't believe it i know you're i
know your ass
i know your ass is the problem it's on
my list i got flipping mending
i got golden and i got a saddle
we can get jurgen white jurgen next
episode okay guys smash like subscribe
look at craft thanks for the supporting
this year so far super fun hope i don't
profess
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom gotta try
this baby on doom
pub g valorent you name it
okay we don't have every game but a ton
of games so the blaster now works with
geforce now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's just a new way to play we're
bringing it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out